When I grow up I want to be famous I want to be a star
I want to be in movies when I grow up. I want to see the world drive nice cars. I want to have groupies
I want to be an example that you can
be funny and be kind and
Make people laugh without hurting somebody else's feelings. And so if by standing up for what I think is right makes me an activist
I'm an activist
Need motivation watch attendees nation. What's that believe nation? It's seven. My one word is believe and I believe in you
I believe you have Michael Jordan
Level talent at something and I want you to find it embrace it and use it to make a difference
so let's get your motivation to
Attend and get you believing in you grab a snack and chew in today's lessons from a woman who went from doing stand-up comedy in
Small clubs and coffee houses to having her professional career
Stunted when she admitted that she was gay
To now women the Presidential Medal of Freedom and being one of the most successful talk show hosts of all time
She's Ellen DeGeneres. And here's my take on her top ten rules of success. Enjoy
Okay, let's kick it off with rule number one
persevere a stand-up comic by trade
She became a household name in the 90s on the ABC sitcom aptly named Ellen. See the truth. I mean be Who I am but
Unprecedented and honest humming. Let me actually put it all on the line. This isn't
I'm gay
her on-screen character coming out
And a real-life parallel with this 1997 Time magazine cover when you're gay and and you're successful in this business
Your whole team says don't rock the boat. Keep it keep it down and I just thought you know
What's equally as important is my career is living my life without shame
And so I just wanted to get rid of the shame
But at the time she was taking a huge risk within a year her audience walked away her show canceled
It would be three long years. She says before anyone would return her phone calls
the fear is that you lose your career and it turned out I did for a while and
Three years seemed like forever. It seemed like I was I didn't have any money left. I wasn't getting any jobs
I didn't have anything and yet like Dorie you persevered. Yeah, she didn't just persevere. She thrived
Playfully joking her way into hosting the Oscars
Nearly breaking the internet
Rule number two live your life with integrity
When I was younger, I thought success
Was something different I thought when I grow up I want to be famous
I want to be a star. I want to be in movies when I grow up
I want to see the world drive nice cars. I want to have groupies
To quote the Pussycat Dolls how many people thought it was boobies, by the way, it's not it's groupies
But my idea success is different today and as you grow you'll realize definition of success changes for many of you
Today's success is being able to hold down 20 shots of tequila
For me the most important thing in your life is to live your life with integrity and not to give in to peer pressure to
Try to be something that you're not to live your life as an honest and compassionate person to contribute in some way
rule number three be
Authentic a lot of people in the audience including myself are content creators
Here at YouTube and I just would like to ask you all what advice you'd like to give us with building our careers
I would say authenticity. I think what-whatever
I think when you if something's happened to you and the same thing that elbahr saying if you have a story
you're probably not the only person with that story whatever it is and
Sometimes the best stuff comes out of the hardest stuff and the worst stuff that you've gone through
So if you've actually experienced something, I don't think anybody should hide any kind of truth
So whatever you have
witnessed or experienced or gone through find a way to express that and find a way to stay and I think people read
Truth and authenticity and I think that's the most important thing for establishing anything rule number four care about your fans
You're in front of an audience all the time
This is a big deal. It's the Oscars. What's the difference? Oh, there's a big difference that
That audience comes to see me and they travel from and god bless them
They travel from all over the world to come to a taping and they wait for a year for tickets
They're my core group of people that get me know me
And and love me and and I feel that and I you know, that's that room is like church
I mean let really never e single day that I do my show. It is an energy. That is like no other energy
When you are with your audience is unlike I think anything I've ever seen
I mean, they really feel that they are and they are a part of the of the show. Yeah. Yeah, they are
I mean, this is our 11th season and and when we started building the studio
It was really important that
the audience was comfortable and it was really important that they were not in the dark that they were lit because they're part of the
Show it's not a spotlight on me. Of course. My lighting is better. I'm a cover girl
I have to look good, but but it's still bright enough that they're part of it
rule number five my personal favorite stand-up
Why did you think it was necessary for you to come out?
You know, you've read some of the mail people say so if you're gonna why not just let that be your business
Why was it necessary for you to come out tell the public?
Why was it necessary for the character to do so because it's okay because it is okay I did
Oprah's show I did the cover of Time magazine and I did a Diane Sawyer interview. That's all I did
That's all I planned on doing
but because it became such a huge cultural thing and 45 million people watched it and
Then and then people all around the world talked and then article was written and then another article was written and then article was written
On that article and then everybody got so sick of it
It got to the point where even Elton John who I'd never met in my life Elton John said we know you're gay
shut up and be funny and I was like you can imagine how much that hurt me because I was like
I don't know. I don't even know. Yeah, I hadn't even said anything. I'd done three interviews
It's funny because I all along that was my biggest fear is that it was gonna get canceled
And I didn't I was not told that it was canceled. I was told through an assistant who read it in the trades
It's no different than at all three. It's no different than
You know robbing stealing lying cheating
Millions of gay people in this country who don't think that being gay is wrong. Why?
Why then it was all kinds of other lessons of learning what it's like to not be
Loved and to be the butt of everybody's joke on television and in magazines
And so I had to learn what that feels like to to not let things like that
Get to you. I never wanted to be an activist. I just wanted to entertain people. I just wanted to make people feel good. I
Remember the first letter I got where somebody
said I saved their life that they were going to kill themselves and that they didn't because of what I did but
since I've witnessed the discrimination and the double standards and and heard about the
statistics for gay teen suicides
I've had to rethink that and so if by standing up for what I think is right makes me an activist. I'm an activist
Rule number six show people
Your brain follow your passion. Stay true to yourself. Never follow someone else's path
Unless you're in the woods and your loss and you see a path and by all means you should follow that
Don't give advice it'll come back and bite you and they ask don't take anyone's advice. So my advice to you is to
Be true to yourself and everything will be fine
And I know that a lot of you are concerned about your future, but there's no need to worry
The economy is booming. The job market is wide open
The planet is just fine
It's gonna be great. You've already survived a hurricane. What else can happen to you?
And as I mentioned before some of the most devastating things that happen
He will teach you the most and now you know the right what the right questions to ask for
Your first job interview like is it above sea level?
So to conclude my conclusion that I've previously concluded in the common cement speech
I guess what I'm trying to say is life is like one big Mardi Gras
but instead of showing your boobs show people your brain and if they like what they see you'll have more beads than you know,
what to do with rule number seven just keep swimming
so my question to you isn't finding nor Dory one of the mantras for me was just keep swimming which is
I'm a plus-sized health and fitness motivator to help women like me you start to engage at this
So to me, it's about the journey embracing the journey. Just keep moving no matter what happened. Just keep going well
Loving who you are the body you're in
So what I be curious to know is what is your life lesson coming out of finding dory?
Did you have that moment that just keep swimming moments that really stood out to you?
Well, my life is that's that's my motto as well. It was my motto
I think okay, it's yours and I'm you know, we'll share. So sorry to now steal it from you second lawsuit now
I'm aggressive
Well, it was it was kind of like my motto it wasn't completely my motto
Because I think if anyone knows my story it is I had to just keep swimming
I you know, my life has been a lot of challenges and a lot of different curves and and
Roadblocks, and so I think that's a great, you know
I didn't come up with Jessica keep swimming but it has turned out to be something that a lot of people
can hold on to and use in their life and so I would say just everything I think I am so
Blessed and lucky that that's part of my character
That I get to say just keeps keep swimming for whoever you are and whatever you're going through rule number eight be kind
Most comedy is based on getting a laugh at somebody else's expense
And I find that that's just a form of bullying in a major way
So I want to be an example that you can
be funny and be kind and
Make people laugh without hurting somebody else's feelings. Rule number nine
give
the greatest thing that I can do is look out and see people
Smiling and hear story is that I make people's days better that I make them happy in and that makes me happy
There's no better feeling than to give something away. I get so much for my audience
I get so much from the show. And it only it's the best thing in the world that I get to give
I just want to say thank you because for five years you'd be my chemo buddy every night
And you help me go to sleep with the law. I just thank you
so
As she continues to give love and hope to these people she receives love and hope for herself
And helping to begin to restructure and redesign the kind of life that she wants
I've learned that you have to give back and I think most people get into this business
to become famous and to become rich and successful and then
Hopefully you grow as a human being and you gain a little depth and perspective and you you realize that it's more
Gratifying to give back and to help people and to you know
Just to be a positive influence than to just be successful and rule number ten
The last one before a very special bonus clip is have fun
Wait, tell them apart
Really if you look at it is if something makes you say, oh my god, yeah guys are so right
That is your back
You're not here you're climbing a pole you're cold
You're
You're climbing a tree. Yeah
Be careful
In your purse those scissors I delights and discard shopping
Health insurance
I've got a really special bonus clip from Ellen on how to be exactly who you are
But before that I want to make sure you're moving from just watching a video to actually taking some kind of action
So I've got my three questions lined up for you question number one. What are you standing up for?
And how can you act on it this week question number two?
What judging are you afraid of that is preventing you from being truly authentic with the people in your life and question number three
What?
Can you do to give more this week write the answers down yourself?
Share them with a friend or put them in the comments below either way
I want you moving from just watch another video and consuming to actually taking some kind of action in your life and your business
Thank you guys so much for watching. I believe in you. I hope we continue to believe in yourself and whatever
You're one where it is much love. I'll see you soon. And enjoy the bonus clip
I get the distinct impression that while you may be
this famous talk-show host
You are a private person maybe even shy I'm an introvert for sure as I have a career despite myself
Because I really am awkward socially. I hate going to big events. I hate having to do small talk
I don't like a lot of attention
It's bold of you being an introvert to not only
Do this show but to also put yourself out there
Realizing that not everyone's gonna like it if it costs me, you know some viewers and if it costs me some money
I'd rather talk about what I think is important than just be you know
vanilla and and try to be liked by everybody that
honesty has coasters especially in
1997 when she famously came out of the closet
Only to have Hollywood shut the door
Advertisers pulled out within a year her sitcom was canceled. Her careers stopped cold
I don't think was a failure, but it certainly gave me a lot of free time for three years to sit still and go
Okay, Who am I without a career Who am I without people loving me did you?
Feel that you had made a mistake and coming out, absolutely no
Absolutely not. It's a mess because I'm I am free. I'm completely
Able to be exactly who I am to have to hide anything
It's just a horrible way to live now turistic world domination. Honey Empire right? I'm grateful
I understand why I'm here I think because I am so open I wanted to think I'm saying it's a bloody brief life
All of you have the potential for enormous
success if you want to know what Gary Vee DJ Khalid Oprah and others know about
Empire building that most people miss check out the link in the description for a free bonus video